president biden is going on the
offensive as the crucial midterm
elections approach during a democratic
rally in maryland last night he put
abortion rights front and center and he
criticized trump supporters calling
quote maga republicans a threat to our
very democracy close quote nancy cordes
is at the white house forest nancy this
is a decision by the biden team good
morning
it sure is tony this was a speech
designed to fire up the democratic base
in advance of the november midterm
elections and president biden went
aggressively after the trump movement
laying out what he says is on the line
in these elections
we'll codify roe v wade
testing out some campaign themes
president biden in maryland thursday
night argued women's reproductive rights
are at stake this november
there's a race to pass the most
restrictive abortion
limitations imaginable even without
exception for rape or incest if the mag
of republicans win control the congress
it won't matter where you live
women won't have the right to choose
anywhere maggot republicans don't have a
clue about the power of women
let me tell you something
they are about to find out
in ramped up political rhetoric the
president took aim at trump followers
especially those in office in this
moment
those of you who love this country
democrats independents mainstream
republicans
we must be stronger more determined and
more committed to saving america then
the maga republicans are destroying
america with just over 10 weeks to go
before midterm elections president biden
and his party are looking to capitalize
on a series of recent policy wins
including the health care and climate
change law gun reform and the new
student loan forgiveness plan it's
completely unfair
which republican lawmakers slammed
thursday
for our government just to say you know
okay well your debt is completely
forgiven obviously they have an agenda
for that they need votes in november the
white house twitter account went on the
offensive calling out republicans like
marjorie taylor green by name for
criticizing student loan forgiveness
even after their own pandemic era
business loans known as ppp were
forgiven by the government
democrats feeling new optimism after
their candidates beat mr biden's 2020
margins in four recent special
congressional elections including in new
york where pat ryan beat a tough
republican opponent by focusing on
abortion rights when the supreme court
ripped away
reproductive freedoms access to abortion
rights we said this is not what america
stands for
candidate biden may have run on civility
and bringing americans together but now
with control of the house and the senate
hanging in the balance he is clearly
ratcheting up the rhetoric tony
yeah
nancy in regards to abortion access
there are a number of new laws taking
effect all around the country what can
you tell us about those
absolutely a bunch of trigger laws
taking effect this week take a look near
total bans went into effect just
yesterday in tennessee and idaho
penalties were tightened in texas and
this weekend oklahoma is going to enact
a law increasing penalties on doctors
who perform abortions now the white
house thinks that all of these
restrictions are going to galvanize
democrats across the country the way
that they did in kansas a couple of
weeks ago when an anti-abortion measure
was defeated at the polls but whether
this issue has as much potency come
november as it does right now remains to
be seen
yeah time will tell nancy thank you very
much